massive demonstrations are underway in
Prague as thousands of Czechs call for
embattled Prime Minister Andrei Babak to
step down bhavish is a wealthy
businessman who leads the populace a and
a party he's under investigation for
corruption and conflicts of interests
organizers estimate hundreds of
thousands of people could show up the
biggest crowds since the country's in
1989 revolution CW correspondent Emanuel
Schatz is in Prague for us Emanuel we
can see huge crowds gathering behind you
what's going on where you are well I
think the images and the someone's
really to speak for themselves we
witnessing here a historic day for the
Czech Republic the million moments for
democracy civic movement which started
this wave of protests around the country
was hoping for just that this amount of
people here on letna park today in
prague letna park a highly symbolic play
place afford Czech people this is where
all the protests starting in 1989 and
this is were today people are gathering
and coming from all passes of live bait
students pension ease active people
they're gathering here to demand the
resignation of Prime Minister and
republish what exactly did they accuse
barbershop well collusion of interest
and also corruption this comes not only
from from her Commission leaks reported
few weeks ago but also from the Czech
Criminal Police which conducted an
investigation into alleged corruption
and alleged subsidies that but babish
would have got from the European Union
more than a decade ago and for which he
has to answer for in front of the
justice but instead of answering to
those accusations but we simply say that
he would stay remain Prime Minister and
he fired the former justice minister and
nominated someone he really trusted and
not really triggered the anger of the
Czech people you see reunited here how
big of a problem is corruption in the
Czech Republic in general
[Applause]
well this is exactly what the people
here want to get rid of it is still very
present in the checkers society but the
Czech people don't want any longer that
corruption is a part of their politics
and I told two people earlier on today
and they told me that they wanted to
come here just as their parents had done
at thirty years ago because they want a
more democratic country something that
Henry Babbage had promised before his
election but hasn't delivered in Menasha
as many things